und er ist ein Mann mit vielen Visionen für
Verbessern Sie dieses Land, indem Sie laufen, um zu sein
Präsident, aber die Reichen wollen ihn nicht
Design heißt hier Kompass
Ihr Thema mit der Zeit werden sie fühlen
[Musik]
New York, wo er geboren wurde
Die Straßen von Brooklyn wurden geschaffen
fing an zu bemerken
und ich wiederhole es und die Sicherheit und Begeisterung
große Energie U-Bahn privat und
lateinische männer auf latinas und ivan vorher
Flügel reduziertes Gehalt
santi aktien und die zeit onkel bernie onkel
bernie kämpft problemlos
Verbrennung
[Musik]
wie jeder
Die Reichen wollen es nicht einmal im Fernsehen
Hier ist es
in den verschiedenen Kandidaten für Stopp und
diejenigen, um die sich o Sports Jones kümmert
Qualität in den Fernsehanstalten ist angekommen
fiel wegen Protests hinter Gitter
Segregation Ich möchte, dass Sie sich das vorstellen
erster Tag nach der Präsidentschaft von
Donald Trump diese Art von Chaos und
Korruption sind in Jobs, die es zulassen
meinen Club zum Präsidenten zu machen
Job Creator Leader Problemlöser
Probleme die Geschichte von Perón und Sanders
Es ist unsere Geschichte
Ihr Vater kam in dieses Land auf der Suche nach einem
besseres Leben